foreign
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the pots of
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships George
Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it is a free call and some say the
advice is worth exactly what you pay for
it the phone number eight eight two five
five two two five Stephen starts this
hour in New York hi Stephen welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for having me on I
appreciate it our pleasure how can we
help
so pretty much I uh I am coming into a
large inheritance and I want to know
more sense of guidance and strategy on
this particular subject because I want
to maximize this amount of money you
know I'm very familiar with the
philosophy you guys have and I agree
with a lot of it it just seems like I
want to be able to turn this into
generational wealth and uh
sustainability for my family
so I was just trying to get your opinion
on that
um
how much did you are you getting as an
inheritance
uh it seems to be upward of 700 000
around there wow who passed
ah it's gonna be my wife's grandfather
I'm sorry
um
wow and um uh so how old are you
I'm 32. you're 30.
32 32 32 okay what's your net worth
uh roughly I would say around three
hundred thousand okay
so safe to say you haven't managed a
large sum of money in your lifetime
no nothing of this magnitude I've uh you
know pretty much achieved everything on
my own but something like this I want to
be able to scale and you know take my
life to a different uh a different level
I suppose yeah great great question and
it's um
uh good that you're feeling the weight
of the responsibility of this rather
than uh woohoo I hit the lotto uh
because right after people say stuff
like that's when they do stupid butt
stuff and so
um you know if you'll feel the weight of
this and here's what I want you to feel
I want you to feel the weight enough to
manage it and do and be very careful
with it but I don't want you to feel the
weight to feel the pressure to dive into
something you know nothing about
that's the other thing I agree with that
so if you feel like oh I got to do
something with this I'm going to put it
all in crypto you know then we would
call you stupid and we'd look up stupid
in the dictionary it'd be your face
right and so we don't want to do that
right so that that's not the point so
the idea being here that what wealthy
people do is over time they build
relationships with people they can trust
in different areas I call them my board
of directors although they're not a
board of directors okay so you want an
independent insurance agent
that has the heart all of these need to
have the heart of a teacher
okay okay you need a tax accountant
maybe a tax attorney
you need a real estate agent
okay you need a
an investment broker smart investor Pro
would be a good one real estate agent an
ELP would be a good one okay you don't
need them because you're necessarily
going to invest today or you're going to
buy real estate today or you're going to
go buy insurance today you're putting
people in your corner that have
expertise in money areas that you don't
have to advise you and teach you
so they're they're the guys you call so
like when I die because it's
predetermined that I'm going to die
first Sharon is going to call the broker
that is our smartvester Pro okay and we
have a long we have a 20-year personal
relationship with him and his wife
Sharon trusts him and that's part of our
board of directors okay Jeff Zander at
Xander Insurance handles all of my
personal insurance and my business
insurance so any insurance questions
Sharon will be on the phone to Jeff and
and I'm on the phone to him if I've got
a question you follow me so we're put a
board of directors in your corner that's
helpful number one number two is don't
invest in anything you can't tell me how
it works and don't invest in something
because you're excited
if your pulse if your pulse rate's up
you're getting conned it should be
yeah I'm trying to
you know I I do invest in myself nothing
in this magnitude and I'm trying to
break into real estate investing and
things like that it's more a sense of I
have a lot of options and I'm trying to
figure out which is the path that's
going to be you know obviously
is the path slow you see Dave the the
The Inheritance is already inequities
now I was trying to I could easily leave
it there put my feet up and say hey
that's it I'm just going to let it grow
up I could roll it over to mutual funds
and not think about it again and you'll
be just fine
exactly but I want to be able to take
this by days this is the difference like
if somebody gave you this money you'd be
able to flip That Into You Know double
it triple it because you're very well
versatile no I I would double it or
triple it over seven to ten years I
wouldn't double or triple it over 20
minutes
no not 20 minutes not 20 minutes not
even not even one year not even one year
right
it's just about being uh optimal I don't
I could easily leave it but I would like
to maybe use it for you know possibly
real estate
um I think I would buy my own my own
real estate first on my own yeah do you
have do you have uh do you have any debt
I had my home and a few student loans
what do you own your student loans
uh 25k what do you own your on your home
um I owe about 438 but it's worth about
700 now so I got some equity in that
phenomenal okay yeah that part where you
said you do almost everything we teach
um is now kind of come out because now
I'm going to tell you to take your 700
and I'm gonna pay off your house I don't
pay off your student loans and I'm gonna
put the rest of it into some mutual
funds for a year
maybe two and then I'm going to think
about real estate as that has grown only
then but
Stephen it's all over you I can smell it
you're not going to do that
you're not going to do that you're
hell-bent on getting on turning this
money into something and proving
something please don't try to prove
something with this money honor her
grandfather's memory he would not have
done the things you're getting ready to
do
don't do them and Stephen I don't know
if you've talked to your wife about any
of this I'm worried that she's going
well Steven said he's got a plan you
need to be on the same page with what
you're going to do and be in full
alignment and you both need to
understand this and you asked for about
generational wealth the best way to
create generational wealth to start with
you and you stop being broke and you
have no debt then we can start to build
something for the future if you just put
a million dollars away at 30 300 that
you've got 700 there and you put it in
mutual funds and in real estate and it
averages 10 percent every seven years it
will double when you're 37 you'll have 2
million when you're 44 you'll have 4
million when you're 51 you'll have 8
million when you're 59 calm down you're
gonna have 16 million
okay if you don't screw this up and go
follow some nothing down real estate
bullcrap on Tic Tac this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place here's
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
well I love tax season said nobody ever
questions about taxes though they're
coming in and we'll help you with those
uh there's a question from one of our
listeners Dave we normally have someone
do our taxes but our accountant retired
I think we have a simple return should
we try to file ourselves with Ramsey
smart tax well you can use their MC
smart tax software it's very easy to use
the more complicated your return the
more likely you would want to use a
professional I personally use a
professional but mine's the size of a
freaking phone book when I get it done
so uh you know that's different
obviously we recommend we're working
with a tax Pro if you've had a major
life change like we retired got an
inheritance adopted a child if you own a
business and file long form on that
probably a pro you're not confident
you're confident though or you want to
save time and stress these are reasons
that you'd want to do this but if you do
get if you get into it and it's just
like ah God I hate this okay there you
go that tells you right there right so I
hate it anyway I hate just signing the
thing much less preparing it so that's
the whole thing
um I see it like buying back your time
and mental sanity when you work with a
pro now people have simple situations
if you've got a 10 40 Easy
you know do a Ramsay smart tax you can
do that as fast as you can do a 1040
easy don't pay somebody 300 bucks to do
that I mean it's just when you can pay
20 bucks I haven't had one of those in
my life so I've always been so nothing
about Dave's life is easy
well I don't have an easy button anyway
but yeah no I mean I've always been
self-employed or had some kind of weird
income or something going on where I
didn't trust my own level of tax
knowledge to do it uh so either way if
you want a pro or you want to use the
Ramsey smart tech software just go to
ramsaysolutions.com
tax our question today comes from our
brand new sponsor neighborly we are so
thrilled these guys are on board with us
it's brought to you by them they're your
hub for Home Services stuff like Mr Root
or Mr Electric you'll see those at
neighborly so if you need to make
repairs or schedule routine maintenance
or find local help for Home Improvement
projects neighborly is your source for
Reliable home service providers in your
area go to neighborly.com and start your
search today's question comes from
Claudia in Mississippi
she's asking under What scenario do you
have to pay capital gains tax on real
estate here's my situation my
grandfather quit claim deeded his house
to me the house is completely paid off
he paid 24 000 for it in 2013 and it's
now evaluated at 190 000. I'm wanting to
sell in hopes to buy a new property I've
lived with him since 2020 and I took
ownership in 2021. under the scenario
would I be liable for capital gains
no
because it's been your name for more
than two years it's been your personal
residence for more than two years a
single person can make a profit of up to
a capital gain of up to 250 thousand
dollars
so that'd be 274 000 in your case
because his basis was twenty four
thousand uh a profit of 250 000 with
zero income tax on your personal
residence
however this was stupid you almost
stepped in it you accidentally are okay
not because you had a plan if the
numbers were different the house value
was much higher this could have been a
different scenario
so never deed property to someone prior
to your death like Grandpa did here's
why
let's pretend that she didn't
accidentally fall under this personal
residence exemption for 250 000 which
saved her bacon okay so let's say that
she didn't live in the property
that would do away with a personal
residence bet get it okay so now it's uh
Grandpa lives there but Grandpa wants to
make sure granddaughter gets it and he
doesn't want to deal with wills and
stuff because he he knows how those
lawyers are right and so he uh you know
this is the kind of crap people do okay
so then he Deeds the property to her
with a quit claim deed which is a
usually a one-page thing and costs six
to ten dollars to register at the
courthouse it's very easy to do this
stupid move now here's what happens when
you give someone property or
I capitalize that stock
if I give George money if I give him a
share of Home Depot stock if I give him
a piece of real estate his basis when he
gets ready to resell it is based on what
I paid for it
and so in this case Grandpa paid 24 000
for it so her basis is twenty four
thousand dollars if she had not lived in
the house for two years it would be
called investment property 100 of
everything over twenty four thousand
dollars would be taxable major mistake
000 worth of taxable income created here
instead had he deeded it to her in his
will at his death it went to her you get
what's called a stepped up basis her
basis becomes the value at the time of
his death apparently he's still alive
but at the time of his death let's say
he passed in this situation her basis
would not be twenty four thousand it'd
be a hundred ninety thousand she turns
around sells it for a hundred ninety
thousand zero capital gains so the fact
that duber Deeds this thing before his
death Grandpa
dad gumya sweet but dumb okay could have
caused her taxes on a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars or more here it didn't
because she happened to live in the
property for two years but so don't give
people stuff uh let them experience let
market value at the time of their death
be their new basis it's a lot higher
than what you paid for it and control
the ownership vehicle not by an early
deed but with either a trust or a will
or both when does it make sense to use a
quick claim deed
what scenarios uh divorces
uh even then though you can get into
trouble uh because most divorce
attorneys make a huge legal error ooh
I'm calling you boys and girls out uh
because here's the thing husband wife
get divorced there's a 260 000 mortgage
husband doesn't get to keep the house
wife's gonna get the house because the
kids are living in the house and divorce
attorneys say well just part of the
settlement is you're going to quit claim
your half of ownership to her and so he
fills out a one page quit claim as part
of the divorce decree boom there we go
but guess what
husband still has a 260 000 mortgage
that's messy in his name on a house he's
not a part of five years later he gets
remarried and wants to have a life and
buy a house can't do it still got 260
000 Mortgage in his ex-wife's name
doesn't own the property but still got
the mortgage dumb
[Music]
you're getting a divorce and doing a
quit claim deed reinforce a refinance or
Force the sale of the house one of the
two
either the wife the ex soon to be ex or
whoever's going to get the house
refinances and gets the other person's
name off the mortgage or we sell the
house and get the name off the mortgage
because you're gonna get stuck and
divorce attorneys do this all the time
because it's easy it's easy but it's
wrong okay same thing here this is for a
different reason though this is uh when
would you use a quit claim deed uh
I just moved property from one LLC to
another the other day I used a quick
claim team to do that to switch the
ownership it's just I already and I own
both llc's so it's not it's a non-issue
right
um when else would you use a quit claim
deed see a quit claim deed means you
here's real estate theory for you
you do not a warranty deed is what
usually transfers in Most states a house
a piece of property and that means if
I'm transferring property to you George
I am giving you a warranty on the title
that I have the title
I am the owner of the title and I am
willing to warranty that and transfer
that to you then if I didn't have if I
didn't own the property and I did that
then you would have recourse back on me
okay but I could give you a quit claim
deed to someone else's property because
all it says is I quit claiming whatever
ownership I have and if I have no
ownership I quit claiming it wow and I
gave it gave you nothing when I quit
claiming it so I could give I could give
you a quick claim deemed to James's
house
I'm in and it would wouldn't do a union
I'm going to quit claiming all of my
ownership which is nothing
wow so if you don't have pure ownership
and you quit claim deeds something it's
of no value and you can really get into
all kinds of crap there so sometimes
you'll use it to do some title cleanup
if there's something more nuanced than
all of that but um I've only ever heard
it mostly in the context of divorces
divorce and Estates grandpa doing a dumb
thing like this or a estate planning
attorneys doing a dumb thing without
forcing a refinance I mean divorce
attorneys not forcing a refinance and
then you get stung and you're stuck with
a mortgage on a house you don't own
anymore
for the woman you don't aren't married
to anymore there's something about this
sounds miserable to me this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
cschm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions which by the
way if you're coming through Nashville
you'll stop by with free cookies free
coffee and lots of nice folk hanging
around watching George and I do the show
through the glass it's kind of like
watching ugly paint dry but you can't
think about it too long it's definitely
weird but we love it we're doing it
every day anyway so you ought to come by
and see us and it's also where we have
the debt free stage which is where Jeff
and Becky are standing hey guys how are
you great having great welcome welcome
where do you all live
Parker Colorado all right well that's uh
Denver right yeah yeah welcome welcome
to Nashville and how much debt have you
guys paid off we paid off 162 thousand
dollars how long did this take about 33
months good for you and your range of
income during that time the range of
income was 135 to 175 000. cool what do
you guys do for a living
I'm in software sales I'm a teacher's
assistant in a special needs classroom
oh very good excellent you guys what
kind of debt was your 162
000. well you're looking at weird people
Dave we paid off our house
officially weird love it what's this
house worth
just looked and it's worth about six
hundred and sixty thousand
retirement accounts we are right around
000. so we're looking at Baby Steps
millionaires way to go guys very proud
of you paid off your house and hit baby
step seven and hit babies up millionaire
status on the Fell Swoop so what's
to go you go we're gonna do even better
we're gonna pay off the house tell us
the story how did you start on this
Ramsay stuff well it started a little
bit further back than that maybe five
years ago I was talking with my brother
and our idea of what I needed to retire
for hitting a number was vastly
different than his and he had about a
goal of double of mine so I started
thinking about what we can do and
shortly after that I got your book Total
Money Makeover and read it and started
to attempt to try and do a budget and
honestly we kind of failed miserably for
a little while
um so I took it to Becky and
we kind of gave up for a while but then
we had our
um like finally we had a moment where we
were in kind of a deep financial trouble
we had uh taken out a HELOC to
um
redo our kitchen but then ended up not
using it but we use basically were
completely cashless we had no money and
all three of our cars needed tires at
the same time
so we needed to get out of our financial
hole and had our never moment at that
time never again yep yep
so uh Becky he comes down and goes uh we
can't even get tires and you said what
it was you know we were tired of and
never having money we were fighting
about it all the time and so it was just
kind of
time to do something else and change
that and
um
I guess the rest is they say is history
so you drug The Total Money Makeover
book back off the shelf or what how did
this work yep we both read it again
together and
um started working on it and did the
budget again and started
figuring things out together and it was
life-changing marriage changing it was
awesome yeah first two or three months
are Rocky and then it starts smoothing
out yeah smoothing out smoothing out by
the time you get here you go why didn't
we do this 20 years ago yes yeah you
need to give each other a little Grace
because it is challenging and I found a
lot of encouragement from listening to
the podcast every day so you guys gave
us a lot of Hope wow and this started as
some brotherly competition you went oh
he's not gonna beat me I got to step it
up yeah he put a vision out there that
was very
um daunting but encouraging that's
amazing so paying off the house is a big
it's it's controversial in today's world
because people are going why wouldn't
you tap into the equity and you guys you
know you did the HELOC you didn't use it
but what would you say to those people
who go why are you paying off your house
that doesn't make any sense
we just always wanted to be debt free my
dad brought me up to not believe in much
debt but we'd had a mortgage for about
18 years and we'd made almost no
progress on it we'd move twice we'd sold
our house for what we bought it for and
then we had a another house that we'd
been paying on for eight years and we
really had not seen it go down very much
so we just attacked it and said this is
it we're gonna do it
yep Wow way to go guys so proud of you
guys very very cool excellent work
how's it feel and I have a payment in
the world and be millionaires amazing
just amazing
it's kind of hard to put it into words I
think yeah what do you tell people when
they say what's the key to getting your
home paid off
I would say there's two things you have
to do whatever it takes
so what was the wildest thing you did
under the whatever it takes heading
I'm in software sales making a pretty
good salary and I drove Uber for a year
she went back into the workforce after
not working for 15 years too oh wow 15
years to raise the kids
and we even had our oldest son get a job
so everybody was trying to do something
to help the everyone's got skin in the
game yeah
and then the other thing I was thinking
about that we talked about too was
the second part is
um you have to believe in yourself but
you have to partner with the Lord
and so believing in yourself gives you
hope but then praying and pondering with
with the Lord really brings his power
into it and there was months that we
should have never been able to make a
payment that we were typically making
and something would happen then we would
have the money and it was just always
there yeah you hit it hard I mean 33
months 162 000 you were popping that
thing
yeah you guys weren't playing
yeah there were some frustrating moments
every time I wanted to
do something on the house or in the yard
or whatever Jeff would say not until the
house is paid off and I was like okay I
know that is what we said yeah never get
remodeled that's the question yeah and
you just cash flowed that yep yep so
what's the uh what's the next big thing
you do we're paid off house millionaires
what do we do
we're gonna go to Belize there you go
there you go have you ever been before
no it's incredible you're really looking
forward to it you'll love it I I don't
know how I don't know how God made water
that blue yeah it's unbelievable you're
gonna love it that's so cool do you dive
are you diverse no oh go get certified
before you go we'd love to it's one of
the best dive spots in the world way to
go you guys very cool
cool all right very fun you guys we're
proud of y'all well done well done
you're why we do this very cool we got
the live and give bundle for you it
includes The Total Money Makeover book
for you to give away and mess with
somebody else's life like your brother
did with yours and the baby steps
Millionaire's book which basically
highlights the what you've been doing
and uh you'll read through it and go
uh-huh and then you can give that away
and encourage somebody and Financial
Peace University a membership to that
again use it or give it away it's all
for you to enjoy thank you for making a
trip to Nashville yeah thank you for
everything you all do to bring
encouragement to people's lives and we
wanted to thank our kids for putting up
with us for these last three years for
saying no to things and for allowing us
to get this done and all of our friends
and family and people at church that
have encouraged us along the way yeah
you've had some good cheerleaders and
you know what the kids got a gift out of
this because they got to see Mom and Dad
learn something new change something
late in the game become new people
transformed and uh then that gives them
hope they can do whatever they want to
do you gave them a lot of power by them
watching you well done that was very
well done love it Jeff and Becky Denver
Colorado 162
000 paid off in 33 months making 135 to
175 house and everything baby steps
millionaires count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
more is caught than taught I've always
heard Rachel Cruz say that and it is so
true most people make bad decisions
because they saw their parents make bad
decisions but this family right here
they're going to start doing things
differently those kids saw their parents
hustle and pay off that for three years
I mean mom went back to work dad's
driving Uber the old man old lady did
What it Took that's what the kids
remember right they did what it took to
win I love it they're not that old but
still I mean that's the way the kids
think about it right sure but a lot of
people do think well Dave I should have
done this in my 20s it's too late for me
now I'm 40. I'm 50. I'm 60. it's not too
late you really can't fix what's behind
you all you can fix what's in front of
you so today's your day 33 months later
you could be debt free Ready set go
ready
set yeah it's your turn Ready Set you
I'm talking to you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today hey
chner and we know there's a whole bunch
of you that are new viewers and
listeners on YouTube TBN podcasts all
our numbers are up this year thank you
very much we appreciate that but that
also means some of you are trying to
catch up on this Ramsey speak the code
the lingo uh what's all this baby step
stuff George what's all this uh debt
snowball stuff Dave hey if you want to
kind of get grafted in and learn this
stuff we'll help you just go to
ramseysolutions.com click on get started
it's completely free we'll help you
figure out where you are in your
financial journey and tell you what we
think your next steps would be and
you'll start to learn the lingo you'll
start to figure out why it is we tell
people to do all this stuff so that's
the plan
ramseysolutions.com click get started
it's completely free Amanda's in
Charlotte North Carolina hey Amanda
welcome to the Ramsay show what's up
hi Dave I lead a class of 20
homeschoolers who are taking your high
school personal finance class yay
awesome thank you yeah 20 of them and
recently we learned that CDs are not
wise Investments
so today in class I proposed to them a
five percent
DD for six months
and as a class we wanted to know what
your recommendation would be
to make that investment
um
I'm sorry I thought we learned that CDs
are not wise Investments
they aren't right and so you proposed to
them a CD
the well that's what there's they want
to know if I think there was Investments
that was a conversation we had on the
table should at five percent which is a
high yield for six months
it's five percent annual yield not six
month yield but yeah
it's not 10 a year so um right and
inflation rates running 9.6 right now
right
so you'll be going backward right
and purchasing power
that's why we call them certificates of
depreciation
good point so the CDs CDs might be okay
to park some money for a short-term
thing a short-term Thing by definition
is not an investment uh and so I
wouldn't use it for an emergency fund
but let's say that I was saving money
for a car or a house down payment or for
a cruise or something I'm going to take
in the fall
okay and I wanted to park my money
somewhere other than in a savings
account I could put my ten thousand
dollars in at five percent and let it
sit till September
and that'd be okay
but here's the here's the trick Amanda
is still didn't do anything
five percent of ten thousand dollars is
five hundred dollars
half of that in six months is 250
dollars so you made two hundred fifty
dollars whoop-dee-doo in the scale of
your life fifty thousand we're doing we
were talking fifty thousand dollars why
would you put fifty thousand dollars
aside for six months
that's what we were talking about in
class what are you gonna do with it
after six months
it was just an opportunity to make a few
thousand dollars in six months
when savings accounts were four percent
I wouldn't have fifty thousand dollars
in a savings account though
unless you had other Diversified
Investments
I wouldn't have fifty thousand dollars
in a savings account past my other than
my emergency fund unless I was saving to
purchase something
you see what I'm saying there's no point
in it why I want the money working
harder than that if it's a long-term
play
if it's a short-term play it's not
really it's it's not it doesn't change
your life it's just negligible at that
point so there's short-term savings 50
000 1250 doesn't change your life much
right so if you have real estate
investments in place and you have
portfolios established and you had an
extra fifty thousand I would put it in
those
in the mutual funds I put it in the in a
real estate or mutual funds that's what
I do every day
what if your real estate Investments are
paid off I would buy more real estate
I'm sorry all of my real estate
Investments are paid off I would buy
more real estate they were mine so are
mine okay then buy some more
but I wouldn't put fifty thousand
dollars at a poor investment just
because I had some other Investments
that were good Investments
good that's what we wanted to know okay
I'm so confused by this call and the
other problem here is if you needed that
money let's say there was a great real
estate opportunity you had the cash for
it and it's tied up in the CD well I
just I think I was on her homeschool
test and I think I just found it
you're not passing I think I didn't
answer the multiple choices as the kids
say you're not passing the vibe check
that's what they say now and they
disagree with you they don't like your
attitude and your tone so you're not
passing the Vibes if we don't like what
you're saying then we automatically
don't like your tone that's how that
works okay I don't know I don't know
here's the other problem let's start
doing
with the CDs Now what was I doing in
that conversation I have no idea I felt
like I was chasing my time I had a good
time I was entertained if that's that's
any consolation that's why we're here
but the thing with CDs is entertainment
you know my my high yield savings
account which is completely liquid I'm
getting four and a quarter now and so to
say hey would you want to lock this up
for the next six months or a year to
make a little bit more and have some
penalties on the interest if you take it
out early and what if the interest rates
continue to go up well you're locked in
at that with that CD at that rate it's
okay if you want to make five percent on
some money that you're going to need six
months from now if you're going to lock
it up at five percent and call that a
long-term investment that's dumb to say
investing in CDs long-term Investments
have to outpace two things before you
make what's called a real rate of return
a real rate of return is adjusted after
taxes and inflation
okay if inflation's running 9.6 you have
to make north of that and inflation by
the way is average over the last 75
years about 4.7 okay so lately it's been
high inflation we all know that uh
before that it was a little bit lower
but the average is around four or five
percent okay and if you figure you're
going to pay taxes on it another couple
of points another two percent or so
you've got to make north of six percent
on your money seven percent on your
money to break even with taxes and
inflation on a long-term investment so
you've got to be in something like
mutual funds where you're 10 to 11 good
real estate that's going to cash flow
and give you an internal rate of return
probably north of 15 somewhere in there
but you've got to be in your long-term
Investments north of five or six percent
or you don't even break even with
inflation and taxes now short-term
Investments you're not really investing
you're saving there's no such thing as
short-term investment there's savings
there's investing investing by
definition has some length to it
and so would I tell you to park money
into a CD in any circumstances for 10
years at five percent and lose money
after inflation and taxes no I would not
that's you know so the only time I've
heard you say put in a CD is when people
get a big pile of money and they need
patience and time and you go just
someone passes away and your husband
died and you got left 400 000 sit on it
in a CD for six months a year and cry
and get your head cleared before you
start making good decisions before you
start making decisions in the middle of
grief or something like that uh just to
give yourself time for the the brain
webs to clear and that kind of stuff but
again that's not a long-term strategy
that's a parking place for a short term
if I'm going to buy something with a 50
000 in the fall it's a parking place
five percent is fine but even then you
need to realize the difference in five
and one
is 1250 and
what 50 bucks or 500 bucks 550 bucks
okay
is that on the 50 Grand yeah yeah that's
right so it doesn't change your life
you know it's like I got in all kinds of
trouble when with the last Biden bucks
thing Biden came out and gave everybody
thirteen hundred bucks or whatever it
was and I said if 1300 bucks changes
your life you don't have much of a life
well you're just snotty and you're a
snob and you're just a rich guy 1300 is
a lot of money you shouldn't say stuff
like that the little people get mad at
you listen you're gonna keep being
little people if thirteen hundred
dollars changes your dadgum life
you need to have a better life than that
where thirteen hundred dollars does if
thirteen hundred dollars fixes your life
you were really screwed okay before so
that's the thing I'm not it's okay 1250
is good send it to me I'll do something
nice with it but please don't think that
fixes anything it doesn't it's not
life-changing money it's not
life-changing money so and when you run
these things out nominally meaning do
the actual math and the actual dollars
it's a bit of a joke usually this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey George camel here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
open phones this hours we talk about
your life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five George camel is Ramsey personality
co-host of the day with me and uh George
I was not going to talk about this news
story but apparently people are doing
stupid butt things because of this news
story so now we have to talk about it
yes so we're not a news network but we
wanted to maybe quote some of the fears
that are out there that have been
sparked due to the SB svb Fallout so for
those that don't know Dave can you do
like an explain like M5 as to what
happened with the Silicon Valley Bank
collapse
yes
okay the Silicon Valley Bank was
collapsed on last week last Thursday I
guess it was
um and uh the reason was pretty simple
number one you need to understand this
about their Bank
the that the vast majority of the
customers in that bank or hedge funds of
venture capitalist and Tech startups
they were not Mom and Pop Granny's CD
was not over at this Bank
that's not who they catered to okay so
to put that in perspective FDIC
Insurance of 250 000 covers your up to
250 000 the government covers your
deposits in the event of a bank failure
right the typical Bank it covers 75 to
80 percent of the deposits
in other words somebody some people have
rich people have five hundred thousand
dollars or or eight hundred thousand
dollars or a million dollars or
something in your local bank but most
people are 250 000 and under this bank
was the inverse of that north of 90 of
the deposits are not covered
that means these were all multi-million
dollar customers
sitting in that bank so these were
players
and they got they done got caught okay
this is what happened so this does not
affect your local bank at all it has
almost nothing to do with your local
bank it's a bunch of Silicon Valley Tech
startups and Venture capitalists from
all over the place I mean I know I've
got two friends in Nashville that are
Venture capitalists they had money in
that bank lost money okay and uh but
they play us all right they're not
they're not this is not not Granny's CD
for God's sakes all right so your bank
is safe calm your butt down this has
nothing to do with that and what
happened was typically what banks do
this Bank included in order to have a
stable
balance sheet a balance sheet that is
very safe to back up the deposits is
they will buy bonds now if you didn't
know bonds have and in bond interest
rates have an inverse relationship with
bond prices what that means is as
interest rates rise Bond values go down
so they had a whole bunch of bonds that
they bought when interest rates were 1.7
1.8 percent interest rates are currently
about four percent on the bond market
which means their bond portfolio had
gone down in value dramatically
and they had billions in bonds so on
paper they had lost money on paper they
lost a ton of money well then they got
scared and a couple people got spooked
and they start unloading a bunch of
those bonds and then the rumor mill
kicks in the venture capitalist boys
come flying in like they do and start
scarfing the money and they closed the
bank that's what the bank runs they
closed but all the customers so your
local bank a is going to cover the vast
majority of depositors you're fine B
there's not a bunch of Playas in your
local bank that's not who's dealing in
there even freaking Bank of America
which I hate and I don't know why
anybody would do business with them
they're horrible but even they have
almost I mean it's like 40 of their
deposits are covered right and and it's
like these guys had it was all rich
people super rich people in there so
it's just number one you wouldn't have
money in a bank so okay so bond interest
rates have gone up Bond values have gone
down consequently though to the new to
the bank crash and the closing of this
bank then they close to others just like
it because they're afraid they were good
FDIC gets to pay for all this crap and
FDIC starts shutting it down when they
smell anything looks just like this they
shut two down two more right and took
them over they'll sell off the assets
they'll collect all the money to recoup
the insurance if there's any money left
or the insurance and there won't be then
they will just distribute that to the
people uh the depositors the
stockholders will get zip which is
exactly what it was trading at 250
issues of capitalism when you screw
stuff up you lose your money
that's for those people that are in that
bank that's what happened and they knew
what they were in every one of them knew
what they were in again your
grandmother's CD wasn't over there
you're okay my local bank is fine I've
got deposits in excess of 250 000 in my
local Bank in excess of all the limits
in my local bank I am not worried about
it one iota not a penny Okay but the
great news is the bond market freaked
out because they kind of caused this
with the interest rates going up and
bond interest rates dropped bond prices
went up
Translation your mortgage rates are
cheaper today than they were this time
last week if you were going to get a
mortgage in the next month or so and get
a house run to your mortgage company
before all the dust settles on this this
is a great time to get a mortgage go to
Churchill Mortgage today and lock in
your mortgage today
because this is an anomaly it may settle
back up by two weeks from now all right
but it dropped a quarter to a half
depending on what kind of mortgage
you're looking at because bond interest
rates went down bond prices went up
because these dubers were flooding the
market with their bonds and the bond
people went oh look at us we support all
the local banks because almost every
local bank everywhere buys bonds to put
on their balance sheet to quote
stabilize their balance sheet it only
stabilizes their balance sheet which is
the great choke of the bond market if
the interest rates are stable but when
interest rates go up from two to five
then guess what your bond prices go down
and then everyone shows up that Bond you
bought that was so stable now is worth
less because you were betting on an
interest rate Market to give you a
stability and that was a dumb move so
here we go all that to say get your
mortgage right now go to Churchill
Mortgage today and if you're thinking
about buying a house and you're just
kind of on the fence this is going to be
your month baby this is going to be the
time to jump in jump online get you a
you know get a smart get a an ELP with
real estate whatever it is you got to do
here this is the time and don't and
people are going and buying gold George
banks are gonna
fall it's like they live in the wild
wild west or something you don't know
how the FDIC Insurance works the entire
federal government would have to fail
for you to not get your money out of
your bank
when you have to less than 250 000 in
quit acting like you're don't Cash Out
conspiracy serious Investments
everything on the internet's true
Abraham Lincoln said that I mean come on
guys you believe every conspiracy theory
out there these banks are not on the
wire they're not about to collapse it's
going to be like 2008. 2008 was not a
banking collapse it wasn't what happened
here turn off the headlines a lot of
fear-mongering happening right now yeah
[Music]
you may need to turn off the news it's
not good for somebody at least a week or
two just it's not good for some of you
you really react poorly to the wrong
information this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsay
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Georgia one of the
things we've noticed about millionaires
over the years back to our bank failure
story
is that
when um
there's breaking news
right breaking news which it was always
breaking something right
um
the millionaire investor
doesn't react
they just sit back and kind of go hmm
that's interesting
the get rich quick person the scared the
the broke person the person who's
destined to stay broke
overreacts over steers the car and flips
it
and go that's it I'm cashing out every
and I'm by Beanie Babies
because they they lose their freaking
Minds you know I'm gonna bite
Bernie madoff's my man you know I mean
you you just you bite off on some of the
stupid butt stuff
when you freak out and and if you catch
yourself freaking out and like you're
like your pulse rate is up you're over
caffeinated you know and
wait 24 hours and turn off the TV and
stay off a Tic Tac
because it's going to tell you all the
bad news and how the world's coming to
an end
breathe
investors that become wealthy and stay
wealthy are the ones that invest
steadily
calmly they do make changes
but they do not over steer
on one little patch of ice that just let
off the gas and roll across the ice
until the pavement's clear again no
suddenly and then there's no spin out no
flip no roll no airbag release in your
life but the people that overreact tend
to and I can tell you in my personal
life I had the times that I've lost the
most money or when I overreacted to
something when I either was scared mad
and I'm you're it's what deloni Dr
Delaney talks about all the time you
know when you're in the middle of trauma
facts are your friends
breathe wait 24 hours until your pulse
rate comes down rethink this look at
what wealthy people are really doing now
I'm not talking about players like
Venture capitalists what they're doing
I'm talking about people that have five
ten million dollars they're steady
they're predictable they're the tortoise
don't over steer yeah well you've said
that we are in the business of selling
crock pots not microwaves and when you
have that mindset you know this blip in
the stock market because of the bank
collapsing we go okay s P's down one
percent big whoop I'm investing for the
long term I'm I'm not I'm not buying
today and I'm not selling today because
of that
although if I were doing one or the
other it would be buying because I feel
like it's on sale because it's an
artificial short-term blip here mark my
words put it on your calendar
one month from today remind yourself to
see if you even remember this
the SVP bank failure in the Silicon
Valley one month from today see if you
even remember it until you bring it up
it won't be top of it won't be top of
funnel it won't be something everybody's
talking about it'll be a distant memory
missed yeah it's also a good reminder to
not invest in single stocks I saw it was
on the top of Jim Cramer's list for
April of 2022. he got fried didn't he
number one choice was Silicon Valley
Bank to put all your money in and uh wow
I think that's it it's a button yeah he
just smashes all the buttons I love Jim
he's so fun I wouldn't do anything he
says but he's so fun I like him I've met
him a couple times guy he's a lotto he's
a he's he's but his whole thing is
single stocks and of course we tell
people not to do that and we don't
bicycle stocks they just sleep better at
night not having it have you ever seen
all the stuff they trash that guy I mean
of course they trash us so what do we
know about they but
um all if people that follow the Jim
Cramer index that if you actually invest
in according to him how much he would
have actually made it's horrendous but I
don't know if it's accurate I mean you
might have actually made money I don't
know but I'm not it's entertaining his
crud though I love the show it's fun to
watch I don't again I don't buy single
stock so I'm not going to act on it
fight but uh I will tell you too on a
personal level he's a fun guy he really
is but poor guy he's got I mean I think
you need somebody to work it's like the
time that I said something about a
tornado and like the next day one hit
yeah you remember that that was poor
timing that was kind of Kramer's thing I
said you tore up Jack I mean like three
people in our office lost their houses
you know and I'm making fun of tornadoes
the day before like a chances of a
tornado hitting you're about nothing and
then Nashville just gets fried the next
day I got destroyed it was a phrase for
that it's aged like milk oh teenage well
Ramsay yeah you're making fun of like
they closed the schools in our area
because tornadoes might come tomorrow
and I'm like your grandparents are
rolling over in their grave tornadoes
might come tomorrow so you close the
schools today I'm like good Lord
everybody buy a helmet for everything I
was going off on it really I was giving
and then the next day we get just
hammered with tornadoes in Nashville and
everybody like Ramsay that didn't age
well no it didn't I got destroyed I
Could Turn Back Time poor Kramer he got
the same thing it's his tornado moment
we all have one the little guy that does
Nashville weather service or whatever he
was all pissed off at me oh everybody
what's his name I don't remember he's
got the big Twitter account
is it big it's big oh I didn't know I
didn't I didn't know I called him a
little guy maybe he's a big guy he's got
subscribers now he has subscribers and
stuff and stuff but anyway yeah he was
pissed off because I made fun of his
tornadoes and don't don't mess with the
weather guys tornadoes you're really
messing with this I'm a meteorologist
sir
one after you apparently I got Radars
and stuff so more moral of the story is
this you're probably not going to die of
a tornado or this bank failure so me and
Jim Cramer were both useless way to put
a bow on it
full circle
John John is in Tacoma Washington hey
John how are you
I'm doing good I hope we can be useful
to me at least I'll give it a shot
brother what's up
uh so last week my parents came to my
wife and I and offered us to rent out
their house
to us uh while they travel the country
and live in different places for a
couple of years but if we did that we
would have to sell our house that we
live in right now and we kind of just
want your opinion on this I heard your
experts on your opinion so you're right
about that why would you do this
well I did dumb in 2020 when I bought
this house because I Justified it to
myself
as well it's the same as paying rent
around here so why not buy a house and I
bought it with three percent down on a
30 year
okay
so uh what do you owe on the house
289. what's your interest rate 500.
2.875 what's the house worth today
400 okay
doesn't sound like you're hurting too
bad to me is the mortgage a huge part of
your take-home pay
when I bought I was before I was married
and it was huge but now it's less than
25 but if we were to pay it off like a
15 it would be more than 25 but you're
right around the bubble and you've got a
great interest rate in the house has
gone up in value why are you moving
again
do you have other debt well
no we're in baby step four and six it's
just we feel like
if we sell the house we might be able to
save up faster and get a bigger down
payment and we're not in love with the
house either like you know I bought the
house was going up faster than your
account you're going to be saving up in
okay
yeah it makes more sense to pay down
your current mortgage than it does to go
save up well you're going to live for
free in your parents house
it'd be two or three we would write up a
contract uh would it be free
no they we would pay the mortgage and
utilities which averages out to about
9.50 a month no I'll pass stay right
where you are
you got a low interest rate your house
is going up in value you don't hate your
house but you're not staying there
forever anyway while it goes up in value
just keep paying on your house let Mom
and Dad get them a renter
even if it's on a third even if I'm on a
30-year mortgage you can pay it like a
15. even if it's a little over the
bubble you're in four five and six start
paying it like a 15 and work the system
nothing's on fire here this isn't worth
uprooting your life for yeah you're not
house poor you're not stuck I I agree
with you I would not have bought it the
way you bought it but the way you've
ended up has worked out for you in spite
of that and so you're in a good place
today
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50 percent off everything
site-wide visit blinds.com today to
learn more
foreign
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions I'm the debt free stage Jacob
and Ashley are with us hey guys how are
you fabulous how you doing welcome where
do you guys live Independence Missouri
oh cool good to have you how much data
have you paid off
sixty one thousand all right how long
did this take it took 16 months okay and
your range of income during that time
see we started about 126 000 and ended
at 144 000. very cool what do you all do
for a living I'm a registered nurse and
I'm a truck driver ah very good what
kind of debt was your 61 000 all of it
was student loans yeah you're nursing
yes okay very good some of both I had
student loans from school long time ago
that were never paid off okay all right
good so how long you guys been married
this may will be two years okay so right
after you got married you looked up and
said boom we got to attack this is that
the story what happened well it actually
started about six years ago I had gotten
in credit card debt and a friend of mine
gave me her book I started listening to
your radio show
um so I did the snowball debt with my
credit cards that kind of turned into as
we were dating we both owed about the
same amount on our vehicles so like well
let's just make this a competition
between each other
and so our dating just kind of wow it's
a bold win with it do you let her win at
that point for courtship how does this
work yeah make me nervous well she won
because I had to stop giving all my
extra payments to my pickup because I
had to save for a ring you know but I
couldn't tell her that so I kind of had
to keep that one kind of tucked off
sounds like she won I won
again and she keeps winning and you're
smart because she won I'm just saying
you were smart there's a figure out a
way to let her win that was a good I
don't even think you had to let her do
anything she's going to win anyway but
there you go well done yeah good stuff
she was on on a mission to get done and
uh so you're working on the cars and
then you get married and the student
loans are all that's left so we kind of
cash flowed our wedding and honeymoon in
that process and then from the day that
we got married we had a combined debt of
61 000 so that was what we did in the 16
months oh very good so you cleared the
cars and previous to that you'd cleared
the credit cards yep yeah all right so
here we wanted to go in with this little
baggage as possible yeah very good
that's the way to do it so I'm curious
was it easier once you combined incomes
to attack this Collective debt
yeah I mean for sure we were in our
individual debt snowballs when we were
dating and then of course engaged we
never mixed anything until the day we
got married like literally until after
the honeymoon actually but while we were
uh engaged we had a fun for the wedding
we had an idea of what we wanted to
spend and we kind of held each other
accountable real real
specific goals and what we gave to that
so that was uh finished off we paid for
the wedding in full the honeymoon in
full and it was early enough that we
could make a couple more payments on on
my truck and then her on her student
loans before the wedding day and paid
off the truck right then you'd already
looked at gosh when we get to put this
together it's going to go zoom zoom yeah
yeah we did the math plenty of times
before the wedding day so we knew about
what time we were looking at and we kept
to it real strict okay newlywed couple
time already who tried to mess up the
wedding budget which one of you
which one of you had picked out
something that you had a little fit
because you couldn't do it he kind of
wanted more things really I was
wondering we can stick to this budget
budget more he was like oh this looks
cool this looks cool yeah but it was
probably it was the good stuff I want a
good photographer and a good DJ other
than that I just wanted a great
honeymoon
I thought it was going to be the flower
arrangements good food and a honeymoon
that's all I don't care about the rest
of it yeah I don't care less about the
bouquet
for sure you guys well done that's fun
all right now that you did it your
superheroes nobody in America has done
what you've done hardly it's pretty
amazing you're standing on the Ramsey
Solutions debt free stage you did it I
haven't paid off sixty one thousand in
addition to all the other stuff in the
story but after you've been married you
paid off 61 000 in just 16 months yeah
what's the secret to getting out of debt
I mean just the dedication and the
discipline of doing it and we'd kind of
like check in with each other every
couple months like okay well we've paid
this much let's you know we just kept
checking in and stuck with it yeah we
communicated a lot we communicated very
consistently in detail about everything
associated with the debt payoff every
check or every month or if we put in
extra shifts or whatever we just kept
really uh close tally on exactly how
long this is going to take so you're
both you're both very much goal oriented
anyway sounds like we tried when you
laid it down you said okay let's do it
game on every little thing every slice
yep we uh we sold we had two motorcycles
we had fun with them but we knew we
could sell them and they were selling
high at the time so we sold those put
the money on it they're kind of a dime a
dozen anyway we could replace them
anytime so at that point I think the uh
um the debt forgiveness that they had
pushed off was getting ready to come to
an end or not the Forgiveness but the
interest was getting ready to come to an
end pretty soon so we really wanted to
get as much knocked out as we could
before that but when they offered the uh
debt forgiveness
um it was about a week before we were
set to make our final payments and it
was we're not stopping now there was no
reason we're here we're not we're not
trusting it we're just doing it there
was no reason to stop all the momentum
we had built up at that time we were
right there in front of it you know so
and if we had have said you know let's
go ahead and let let them finish off
this for us we'd still be sitting there
with these balances right now wow so you
did a debt eviction instead of debt
forgiveness which I think is the better
path because you you're in control at
that point Yeah man so George that that
is the script The Narrative that he just
laid out is The Narrative of people that
win versus I'm going to wait on the
government to fix my life or the people
that don't win and so this is you know
is I take control I take agency I take
control of my life of the controllables
in my life and I'm not going to sit
around and wait on the DMV to make my
life better have you ever thought about
government Service as an oxymoron
seriously so I'm not going to wait on
Washington to make my life better I'm
going to go take this thing and I'm not
gonna if they had stopped at based on
the news they'd be sitting here right
now in debt and they wouldn't be on that
stage and a year from now same thing in
a year from now same thing so people
that take control of their lives are the
ones that win I'm so proud of y'all
you're rock stars man you're amazing you
can't say rock stars anymore after that
Super Bowl commercial but yeah this is
it was amazing very well done thank you
good work very cool Your Heroes I can
say that for sure I appreciate it
because in America today you're highly
highly highly unusual we got a copy of
the whole live and give bundle for you
that's the baby steps millionaires book
number one bestseller that's the next
step on your journey for sure The Total
Money Makeover book you can give to
someone that's inspired by your story
and say this is what we did same thing
with Financial Peace University
membership we're going to give you all
three and uh people buy that live and
give bundle and give it take pieces of
it give it away we're going to give it
all to say thank you to for coming from
Independence Missouri to Nashville to do
your debt free scream newlyweds Jacob
and Ashley they are goal-oriented people
people oriented people win you just
can't stop them 61 000 paid off in 16
months make it 126 to 144. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
I love this so much it's powerful
go ahead it's just amazing to me that
they decided we're not gonna wait I get
messages every day and people are going
George should I wait because what if
what if the government and I go just
repeat that back to yourself what if the
government
stop right there you know what to do
but they people live in fear and they
get paralyzed by the what ifs well
here's what's really interesting I mean
I've been doing this so long now that
that I pick up
um just because of 30 years of standing
in front of dead free screams you pick
up the little nuances in their body
language with each other the uh the way
they're talking about it like I said you
know who almost broke the wedding budget
and they're like uh that's a dumb
question neither one of us did you see
that they kind of got this quizzical
look on their face like are you gonna
take the phone nobody you fool I mean uh
he tried but nobody was going to break
them we had a plan we're sticking to the
plan we're sticking the plan we're
sticking the plan because we're not
victims we're Victors and uh it's
perfect I mean that couple having
conquered that in the first 16 weeks 16
months of their marriage can now conquer
they can slay any dragon that comes at
them because they know how to fight
together because that same mentality
Works in every area of your life you
don't have to fight each other you need
to fight together the enemies outside
your house not inside your house this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
was the last time you were excited about
a Monday what if instead of waking up
exhausted you felt exhilarated that you
can't wait to get to work because it's
another day to fulfill your passion
you know sometimes around here I get
tired but I don't dread coming to work I
might be tired because we're on the road
we're working a bunch of hours travel is
draining all that kind of stuff but I
don't hate it
in a world where the bare minimum Monday
trend has taken the place of quiet
quitting it's clear people are craving
meaningful work but finding the career
you were born to do can be difficult
when you don't have the right tools
that's why career expert in Ramsey
personality Ken Coleman created the get
clear assessment career assessment to
help you discover your top talents
passions in a clear mission statement
that will help you find the work that
the world needs you to do after taking
the quick assessments you'll get a
custom Report with everything you need
to take that first step towards a
meaningful career and that's not
mythology it really works go to
ramseysolutions.com
get clear
ramseysolutions.com Claire so George our
ratings are up on podcasts on YouTube
everywhere we go
and I think the reason is is that people
are doing the three things that we ask
them to do and it's very helpful to us
guys all kidding and snarkiness aside
it's very helpful if you will do a
couple of things yeah number one is
share the show so you've got friends
you've got a social media account just
posting a link telling them about it
super helpful the other one is
subscribing so you might listen to the
show we don't realize you're not
subscribed you're not following on
Spotify or YouTube or all these places
and that helps us as well and so the
other thing you can do is leave a review
and so if you enjoy the show we love to
read those reviews and see what you guys
think about the show and don't be snarky
and just leave like negative reviews you
can save those for the YouTube comments
or something we want to spread hope and
the way you do that is by telling people
how the show has impacted you mama said
if you ain't got anything nice to say
don't say anything at all that was
before the internet existed now
everyone's gotta they've got their bull
horn out there now everybody's got an
opinion but listen just you know if you
don't like the show quit listening it's
okay we can deal with that I always
wonder who those people are every day
they're listen as a hate listen or
something just find a new show hate
listen I don't listen to things that
make me mad every day
I don't hate listen to anything yeah you
got enough to get you riled up you don't
need that well that's true I have that
but um but a special kind of boredom
where you have to seek out things to
make you angry
you need help yeah there's kind of an
addiction to it almost now it's kind of
weird but anyway hey please help us
subscribe
follow and leave a five star review John
is with us John is in Fort Collins
Colorado hey John welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey thanks how are you doing better than
I deserve how can we help
well quickly maybe not a quick question
but a question I just retired at age 63.
I have health insurance and a severance
sort of an early retirement thing until
I hit 64.
but the questions I have and I can
answer questions you have with regards
to our portfolio but do we need
long-term care insurance if so how do I
fund it and then also your thoughts on
maybe taking a pension that I have that
I can take as a love son and putting
some of that into an annuity to offset
the market
um never consider that before and to
your point on some of the previous calls
don't want to make any fear-based
decisions especially on the LTC case so
would welcome your Insight yeah okay
long-term care insurance you if you do
buy it never buy it bundled with other
insurance products
only buy freestanding policies way too
expensive the other way all kinds of
hooks and gotchas and loops and the
other stuff just if you're going to buy
long-term care insurance just go to an
independent insurance agent have them
shop long-term care only there's a lot
of these companies are bundling with
whole life other life insurance products
or suck they're horrible the ratios are
nasty bad and uh and boy do they know
how to sell it it's a it's a slimy
product so anyway having said that uh
just long-term care if you need it now
here's the thing here's your long-term
care exposure if you're under 60 you
have almost no long-term care exposure
you said six three though didn't you
yes I'm 63 my wife is 60. okay so now
you're starting to have some long-term
care exposure long-term care meaning
nursing home care or In-Home Care in the
ability you had a long-term
debilitating situation
um early onset dementia or Alzheimer's
or whatever or you just get old and the
nursing home comes into play whatever it
is all that kind of stuff all right so
now the here's the statistics for you
the typical long-term care situation is
the average person stays two and a half
years
and right now it's running 80 to 100 000
a year
so this is a two hundred and fifty
thousand dollar average exposure
so if you have five million dollars
you're self-insured you just pay for it
okay okay if you have five hundred
thousand dollars I don't I want you to
get long-term care insurance
because if because typically what
happens is 75 percent of you ladies out
there will outlive your husbands and the
typical scenario is Papa goes into the
nursing home Burns through two or three
hundred grand of the 500 Grand Nest Egg
dies and leaves mama with only 200 Grand
or Burns through 300 Grand that's all
they had and uh that sounded like a lot
of money too and then they're mad at the
nursing home like the nursing home did
something wrong and so you don't want to
do that so what's your net worth John
uh net worth is 4.2 million that was
self-insure
okay and just it's funny you say that
because I was thinking based on our you
know I've been following you a long time
and helped us tremendously over the
years but
um we did meet with an advisor that had
recommended one of these Insurance
products and it made that sense to me
because as I look at it what you were
paying for that would be 20 000 a year
for my wife and I the long-term care
piece that came with the insurance
really wouldn't be enough to cover more
than six months so I'm glad you cleared
up here's what's going to happen at our
house okay we won't be going to a
nursing home
I've got a like you I have a substantial
net worth okay if something happens to
me and I am bedridden or I need
assistance we will bring in full-time
care
it's as cheap as a nursing home and it's
a highly increased quality of life
now and if uh if Sharon if something
happened if something happened to one of
us and the other ones left behind the
kids are going to pay the bill and I'm
gonna pay the bill and the kids are
going to make sure the person's showing
up and taking care of me in the house
because I'm rich enough that I'm on a
full-time freaking nurse taking care of
me that's what amounts to right and
that's really can you do that for a
hundred grand a year
pretty dad come close right right and
that's what a nursing home costs so
that's it's not like you're spending
twice as much because you're some rich
guy or something you're gonna but that's
what's gonna happen at the Ramses
um will not only I'm not mad at nursing
homes I think they do a wonderful job
and they serve a wonder and so it's a
actually a Ministry for a lot of people
in a lot of situations but choosing that
versus me and a series of Staff taking
care of my wife if something happens to
her and she's there I that's what we're
doing I'm not gonna do it by myself I'm
gonna get help but I'm gonna get medical
staff because we can afford it that's
why we worked our butts off all these
years you know
Amen to that
um any feedback or any suggestions on
where that would come from because of
course the Market's declining that right
now I don't have to dip into the
portfolio where would you if you want to
get 100 Grand a year where would you get
it it's not that big a deal
um well I'd have to pull from my
investments now you know we'll be okay
100 grand out of 4.7 I think you'll
probably be okay
this could go until you're 162. see you
there
yeah okay I would also consider that I'm
firing your advisor John because it
sounds like they're an insurance
salesperson in advisor's clothing and
that worries me um it's somebody we met
that's a
no I don't want to give too much detail
it's fine but I just I always get
nervous when someone goes yeah my uh my
financial advisor is trying to sell me
on whole life yeah you got a whole life
insurance salesman yeah there that's
yeah because got to tell you there's no
Smart Vista Pros to sell whole life
uh people on the people in the financial
business don't sell that crap the only
people that sell that crap are insurance
people that's it I mean and then they
say well I'm a financial advisor bull
crap you're an insurance agent
something different Georgia's right and
so your new friend is an insurance agent
let's just call them what they are and
they sell bad long-term care just for
the record wouldn't want anybody to be
confused about this this is the Ramsay
show
foreign
[Music]
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five George Campbell Ramsey
personality is my co-host it's common
sense for your dollars and cents if
you're the guy who pulled your money out
of Bernie Madoff just in time to put it
according to crypto and pulled it out of
there just in time to put it in a safe
Bank in Silicon Valley we're your place
we can help people like you
I gotta hear your story
[Laughter]
I put it in the bank because it's safe
one would think
oh
for this Andrea is in Long Island hey
Andrea how are you
hey Dave and George it's wonderful to
speak to you thank you for taking my
call
um before I ask my question really
quickly my husband and I have been
followers of Ramsey since January of 21
and as of February of as of last
February we are completely dead free so
awesome way to go so
now to my question
um George and Dave my mom and I
purchased the home back in 2004 I was
obviously much younger
um I am married now uh husband two girls
and the house is becoming kind of small
my mom wants to move out
um you know just to have her space she
wants to rent something uh initially So
and I've been pretty much paying the
mortgage for the past 15 years uh just
her financial situation hadn't hasn't
been uh that great but she can afford um
you know a rent going forward so my
question is
I want to be able to be fair to my mom
obviously she is owner of this house
half as I am we don't want to sell the
house we are comfortable in terms of
paying the mortgage but I want to be
fair to my mom so I'm trying to
understand we haven't had that
conversation yet but I know we will have
it what would my responsibility be in
terms of
you know giving the half to my mom would
it be the half of what the house is
worth what we owe the the the market
value so I just I'm calling just for
some guidance to do the right thing
what's the house worth
uh 637 000. okay and what do you owe on
it
okay
all right
hey you've been here for 19 years you
said have you refinanced
we uh we did once and then we had to uh
modify the mortgage
great
um so a hundred thousand of that 484.
it's kind of like on standby we're not
being charged interest for that but if
we refinance or if we sell it obviously
I'm going to be responsible for that
no something's wrong with your equation
okay you don't have a hundred thousand
dollars on standby do you have an open
line of credit against the house and
have not drawn on it no
no no
um just the the mortgage papers say that
a hundred thousand of that amount is not
being they're not charging me um
interest on that amount why
oh because we kind of modify the
mortgage remember if you remember back
in uh
yes yes well we we uh we kind of refine
I'm not refinance but we modified it we
modified everything and it's still
something in our interest rate so you've
paid the mortgage payments did Mom put
down any of the down payment
my mom and my dad at that point they put
about uh 20 I'm sorry ten ten thousand
dollars how much did you put down at the
time I think I may have put like five
okay
all right well um to start with we're
not dealing with uh 637 we're dealing
with what the net proceeds would be if
you sold the house which would be about
85 to 90 percent of that okay and so
about sixty thousand seventy thousand
less
um
which means we're dealing with about
ninety thousand dollars of equity is all
okay uh she put in 10 you put in five
and you paid all the payments
um
I you know
if you want a mathematical formula for
what's fair I don't know what your
mother is going to say but
um your 50 50 owners but you've not been
50 50 contributors and you obviously did
no written agreement on this whatsoever
no no that was dumb okay
um
I guess uh a a quick and dirty would be
to add up all of your payments
add 5 000 to it
and see what percentage of the property
you own then
okay like how much are your payments
been
um well since the
well I I haven't I haven't done
obviously what's your payment now oh
sure it's 28 12. 2 800
okay all right and you've done this for
how you've done this for 19 years
no no no it was much higher before it
was close to five thousand
that's why we
do yeah but you bought the property 19
years ago
correct all right and so sheesh
uh if we add up all of the payments
um
she doesn't own much
because you know you guys hardly put
anything into it the majority of the
investment in the property has been
through the payments agreed correct and
so if we add up 19 years of three to
five thousand dollars a month
um and we said okay that is your percent
and she put into and plus five thousand
dollars and you put in she put in ten
thousand dollars you're going to end up
owning 90 of the property if we use that
formula right and that's not inaccurate
by the way
she paid zero on the payments and lived
there for free for 20 years
yeah well
I got back for 10 grand we would call
her happy
for the last 15 right so about four of
those my mom and dad
profitable so they did make those
payments so I just paid the last 15
pretty majority okay so 75 let me give
you a math formula Okay add up all the
payments that they paid plus ten
thousand dollars
add up all the payments that you paid
plus five thousand dollars okay and then
those two numbers are 100 percent and
either one of those numbers as a
percentage of 100 percent
okay so I think that you are going to
end up still owning 90 of this house
because I think about 90 of the money
has gone in is yours I could be wrong
and how will you come up with that money
to give to them
well that's
yeah that's what I have
because if you wanted to give her ten
thousand dollars where would you get it
okay so
um I would I would say that I mean we're
in baby stage three right now right
um so after baby step three you would
just say rub and give her some money
okay yeah because I think you're gonna
owe her no more than ten or twenty
thousand dollars if our formula
becomes the agreement that you guys come
to
that's a fair formula but um
but I don't know I mean she may think
she owns fifty percent of it even though
she didn't put in fifty percent of the
money
that's possible I don't know what mom
thinks yeah it's just um
pouch this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
folks we've been working on an exciting
new event with Ken Coleman it's called
Career breakthrough
whether you feel stuck in your current
job because of fear and doubt or you
have an idea you want to pursue and you
don't know how to get there or you just
need someone to tell you you can do it
that you need to do this Ken Coleman is
that person and his event career
breakthrough is for you you can join Ken
live in person this spring for an event
that will give you Clarity confidence
and courage
to do the work you were born to do no
more sitting on the sidelines or playing
it safe time for a breakthrough you can
join Ken at his career breakthrough
events
Kansas City Missouri April 20th Chicago
Illinois May 16 Atlanta Georgia May 18
Texas May 23rd tickets started just
fifty dollars head on over to
ramseysolutions.com events and get your
tickets right now Igor's with us in Kona
Hawaii hey Igor how are you
good good Dave how you doing today great
Igor or Igor
uh Igor Igor Igor I'm sorry I messed up
I apologize hate to mess up somebody's
name there's nothing worse how can I
help Igor yes uh we're actually
um out of plant we're trying to make a
decision whether or not to update one of
our cars buy a new car and
uh put the other car as a rental here as
you know tourism is a big thing here and
at this point in time
um we have you know no debt
um we do have
um you know a good financial situation
and we're looking to you know buy a
house next year so what we're trying to
figure out is do we go and pay cash for
this car and you know put our other car
as a rental and or do we just keep on
piling away cash until we're ready to
buy next year if we were to buy the car
it'd be around 30 000 if we were to put
the other car as a rental we'd be making
about anywhere from about 1500 to 2 000
a month
um is our you know rough estimates and
that's basically the decision we're
trying to figure out and make another
thing is you know we have a baby that's
coming later this year so
congratulations
thank you thank you so we have about you
know with taxes that we have to pay here
shortly and you know some medical
expenses that we have coming up we have
about forty thousand dollars worth of
expenses coming up in the next I would
say you know two to three months which
is involves cash to pay for
what's that say what again what's your
experience so
uh so well our tax our taxes we're
filing we should be uh it should be come
in and we'll have to pay about 30 000
you know between federal and state and
whatnot and then for our medical will be
about 10 000 you know I have a shoulder
surgery I have to do which will be about
five thousand dollars you know because
we do have medical insurance and then
um the baby will also be about five
thousand uh because we do have insurance
but they do charge a uh a deductible
yeah yeah
um
okay so how how did you end up 30k in
the hold of the IRS
well no we don't owe them this is just
um based off of this is based off of
um you know our last year's tax bill
um you know of what we earned that's
roughly what we paid um between state
and federal this year we earned more so
once we uh submit those taxes
um it'll be right around that amount too
do you have a thirty thousand dollar
bill you're not you're self-employment
yeah self-employed that's what I mean
why are you not doing quarterly
estimates
um that's a great question how long have
you been self-employed
um about I'd say three years okay you
got a big town you got big time
penalties coming your way brother
because you didn't do quarterly
estimates you're required in the second
year of your business by IRS regs to do
quarterly estimates and withhold on
yourself and pay in quarterly what you
owe uh by not doing that you've added
three or four thousand dollars to your
bill
okay so that's something we're
definitely going to look at yeah you
need to get a professional professional
tax advice quickly and stop doing it the
way you're doing it but okay so you need
40K out of your pocket and a down
payment for a house and a baby's on the
way and there's a shoulder surgery the
last thing you need somebody driving
your car is a rental you have enough
things going on here you have enough
liabilities hanging around you right now
you got enough things going on in your
life and you're trying to buy a house
how much money cash have you got
so as of right now we have 135 about in
cash and we we have you know two paid
off cars
um which we bought in cash so so that we
have no idea no the goal if I'm you is
uh have a paid for house as soon as
possible
at the end at the end of the story five
years four years ten years whatever it
is okay
um in order to do that I'm gonna put
down as much as I can put down in order
to do that I'm going to put as little
towards anything else as I can and put
the largest possible down payment
obviously we've got to take care of the
shoulder and the baby and the IRS
obviously there's nothing in this
equation says you have to buy a car this
year this is not the year for you to do
that and it's certainly not the year to
put a car out on the rental program
um and uh just in general I mean Airbnb
is Tough Enough that's the same thing
for houses that you're doing with your
car right you're running that turo or
whatever it's called
yeah yeah and um the difference is
houses go up in value and cars go down
in value
so that scares me as part of this and
someone wearing the wear and tear on
that car is going to be very high
comparatively to you driving it with
extra liability and the yeah I don't I
want to check with your insurance guy I
don't know how they're insuring these
things I think you need extra insurance
and turo includes some but I've seen
people who get denied for their claims
and it can be real dangerous so I mean
there's even there's even situations
where somebody's like delivering pizza
and their like their car insurance will
say well we don't cover commercial
vehicles they don't cover you while
you're delivering the pizza that kind of
stuff and you want to fool with this for
fun as a side hustle you can do that
later on but you got enough going on man
yeah you got you got your a plate full
man you run your own business even yeah
you just hadn't you've never seen a deal
you didn't like though so uh yeah stay
away from this one I've seen those Tick
Tock videos Dave where they go this is
the best side hose I'm making two grand
a month you know it's all the upside
none of the downside yeah like nobody
yeah
all the all the smells people could
leave in your car just visualize all of
them okay
um and they'll all be there once you're
done with this I'm just saying this is a
bad idea
there's a lot of stuff I'll run out but
my car is not one of them
sorry America if you were hoping to
drive Dave's car not anytime soon Sean's
in Portland Maine hey Sean how are you
hi Dave hey George thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
my wife and I had about 100K in student
debt loans and we got gazelles hence
back in 2020
um we paid off a pretty good chunk and
I'm left with
just under 30k left
um and one of the things that I've been
kind of sitting on is whether to wait
out this my the loans that are left are
my Federal loans
and right now there's that interest uh
waiting period and I've been taking
advantage of that paying monthly
um and so what I'm trying to figure out
is I've got some money on the side that
we usually have as a an emergency fund
and whether or not to pay that use that
money to pay off the debts entirely how
much money
so uh there's about 50k in a high yield
Savings Bank pay it off today is that
all you're debt the 30k in student loans
yeah no card debt no credit card debt so
today you could be debt free with twenty
thousand dollars in the bank
yeah I guess the reason I've been
cautious is because that's like three to
six months and I know it would go down
uh well if you're following our plan
you'd pay off all the debt before
getting the fully funded emergency fund
and you'll still have twenty thousand
that's got to be some substantial
emergency fund still
yeah no it would still leave us pretty
comfortable and you can add more to it
you're dead free today the kind of
person that will pay off their debt
today instead of waiting on the
government to do it for them is the kind
of person who will be vastly more
successful in 10 years than the kind of
person who sits and waits on the
government to pay off their debt
you politicians you see what you've done
listen to that guy
he's sitting there with the money to pay
off the debt that he owes the taxpayers
he's not doing it because you idiots in
Washington you guys are morons
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
everybody
thank you
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Adam
and Paula are with us hey guys how are
you better than we deserve Dave welcome
welcome where do you guys live
we live in Sandy Utah ah fun well
welcome to Nashville good to have you
how much debt did you pay off 154
842.77 love it how long did this take 17
months four days wow and your range of
income during that time uh 225 000 to
315 000. goodness gracious what do you
guys do for a living well I'm an ER
nurse I work in the level one Trauma
Center a registered nurse I'm an air
traffic controller okay wow great jobs
wow so what how did you guys just take a
bunch of OT is that you got your income
up almost 100 Grand you betcha and laid
all of it on the data yeah yep I went
from working three 12-hour shifts a week
to anywhere between like five or six
days a week and it was a lot
wow I hope you're back to regular now
yes yeah what kind of debt was the 155
well it was student loans
um a car
uh solar panels and a 401k loan from her
wow okay oh my goodness so something uh
made this really really important
17 months ago what happened
well 17 months ago we actually our
journey actually started before that
um we had started having the two of us
some increasing problems in our health
and we actually went on a health Journey
um and that actually and we had success
with that and we have always done Dave
ramsey-ish things prior to that and so
when we realized hey we committed we had
success let's do it with our finances so
we did we then got gunsell intense and
yeah we succeeded because they say uh I
remember reading this a long time ago
and I'm sure it's probably still true
that air traffic control is one of the
highest stress jobs on the planet is
that right a number two behind an ER
nurse yeah yeah you did to pick out two
trauma-filled situations if either one
of you make a mistake lots of people die
yeah I mean this is like wow but I mean
seriously isn't there a high uh
incidence of uh like heart attack and
stress related things other guys gals we
have to maintain a medical so I mean
that was a concern too right but now I'm
not concerned about that anymore yeah I
know but yeah we do tend to be an
unhealthier Bunch especially as we age
but yeah well it's just very very
important your work is so detailed and
ER nurse is exactly the same way it's a
good point yeah both of you have this uh
very very intense situations and so your
health Journey helps you with a lot of
that yes I'm sure a Stress Management uh
by being healthier your body being in
better shape you can manage that stuff
better your mind's clearer all those
kinds of things and then on top of that
uh then you say oh well if we can apply
a proven process to that we're both
processed people we could apply this
Ramsay process and maybe maybe ish is
not the plan that's that's that's that
sense of your story yeah that's exactly
it okay wow yeah nothing nothing says
let's de-stress by working extra to get
rid of all this debt but it was a
temporary sacrifice for you guys most
people would hang on to that debt for
the next 20 years I mean we had that
debt for 17 years wow it's embarrassing
yeah we had it for 17 years and we got
rid of it in 17 months wow yeah that's
amazing most people are just going well
this is just part of life and you guys
went no we're going to attack this thing
so hardcore that we never have to deal
with debt again this seems like a a very
definitive liner on it at some point do
you remember the actual conversation
when it got real I do okay so we
ordered a car George's kind of car and
oh a battery I can't say in front of
Dave he gets upset with wheels yeah and
and while I'm watching YouTube videos on
that car you know how YouTube kind of
sneak snakes around and gets you into
all sorts of other so it's financing
started and then you popped up again and
we've been I popped up in Tesla
financing algorithm yeah something
somebody messed up yeah
yep and so we I started watching more
and more and then the car got delivered
and then I'm just watching it more and
more and I started that's where it
started and then I went to her and I
said you know we we lost 130 pounds
between two of us and I was like we
didn't do that until we committed we
didn't just like hey today we're just
gonna give up no I said hey no more
credit cards no more like at the end of
the month 1200 Bill nope nothing we're
gonna go right back into payoff and I
want this done I want it out of my life
and there's one phrase that she used to
say to me that ground my gears you
remember what that was I used to say
that I'm gonna work until I die I used
to say all the time because we I knew we
had that much debt and I think I've um I
see my parents uh my mom she is still
working and she still has a lot of debt
and I didn't want that to happen to our
kids and but I felt like that was
happening to me so I kept saying it and
he I knew I bugged him a lot a lot so
yeah so because it's kind of a hopeless
yeah I felt hopeless I feel like I was
just honestly going to just be working
until the day I died so the car is
delivered you mean it came to the thing
but you didn't take delivery no we we
took delivery of it and we talked about
it because at that point your your
formula right two years you know not
they were like well we can sell it but
we we just paid it off we put it in the
snowball and that was oh so you still
got that yeah well we we didn't commit
until we'd already had the car like we
started it's a because it was a
three-month process I kind of condensed
it for you but like yeah that's what had
happened we did have that talk a couple
times about selling it okay so you you
it's sitting in the driveway when you
have this conversation yeah I thought
you meant delivery at the dealer okay
wow okay that is wow what was harder
losing 130 pounds or paying off 155 000
in debt they were both weird like that's
the that's why we got here is because
that was so weird it's that was weird
and I was like Hey we're already weird
let's just keep being weird let's keep
it going yeah and yeah that was the big
thing too was during their 17 years we
felt like such victims because we got
run over by the student loan thing you
know your documentary spelled that out
really well we were we thought we were
weird though on that much but in fact
that's normal and I said one point we
were paid off three thousand dollars in
principal and forty two thousand in
interest that was a low point
so but we stopped being victims that was
the big thing over this thing I'm done
I'm not gonna have anybody else pay it
off I'm paying it off we were going to
pay it off and so that was it
no more victims we're gonna we're gonna
tackle this so Paula Mr Tesla walks in
and says no more credit cards we're done
and now that I got the car we're done is
it hard to take them seriously at that
point I mean did you not go say what I
know I know well I mean in his defense I
really did want the Tesla too I really
did like it I really do like it and but
on the other hand I am also comparing
like if one of us is the spender I was
always the spender I love to spend but I
knew I mean I knew we had a change and
so I was totally on board I was totally
you know that the interesting thing is
sometimes it's the other way sometimes
we have folks come on here and they say
you know while I was getting out of debt
I realized I could control myself and I
lost 100 pounds you know I've heard that
I don't know a bazillion times over 30
years and you guys are the opposite the
fact that you won on the health front
lost 130 pounds between you uh gay you
said okay we can control ourselves
self-control is a fruit of the spirit we
can do this and if we can do that here
we can do that there so discipline the
old saying discipline begets discipline
because you start to trust yourself you
start to believe I can do this and it is
a hope thing you know the losing the
weight gave you hope gave you belief
that you could do it you could apply
those same principles to something else
exactly and give you confidence and
that's very cool it's never too late to
right like I mean 17 years you know if
we're getting into we're low 40s now and
we're like nope we're we're going to
take care of this and yeah along the way
we involve the kids a lot more than I
was involved growing up with money so
they are well aware bring them up give
us our names and ages while they're
doing that I'll tell you we're going to
give you the baby steps millionaires
book The Total Money Makeover book and
Financial Peace University uh if you
have those or don't have them use them
or give them away your choice or live
and give bundle to say thank you for
coming all the way to Tennessee to do
your debt free scream what a good
looking family you guys are amazing
congratulations this is thank you and
this is Sierra she's nine and this is
radic he is eight all right and uh 130
pounds less and 155 thousand dollars
less there's a lot less up there I like
it and yet you're living more abundantly
now absolutely in all cases yeah they
feel better they look better their
clothes fit better and they can afford
them
count it down let's hear debt free
scream
[Applause]
that's how it's done
I feel like I go run through a wall now
ah oh they're impressive nothing's
stopping these guys I'm scared of them
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture today Proverbs 21 20 the
wise have wealth and luxury but fools
spend whatever they get
Shaquille O'Neal said it isn't about how
much you make it's about how much you
keep
well thanks Shaq good stuff open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Brandon's in Atlanta hey
Brandon welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi George uh thank you for
taking my call I appreciate it uh pardon
me I'm a little bit nervous no trouble
what's up um well I I have a mountain of
that uh I should have called you years
ago I've known better I just keep making
poor decision after Poor decision
our total personal debt is about
687.
how much of that how much of that is
mortgage
mortgage is 240.
and a big part of the debt is of the
personal debt is business that total is
about 337.
um the worst part I think the worst part
about our situation is that the business
every year we're about 30 000 short
uh so we just keep going into more debt
year after year with the business
so the the original loan we'd be down to
about 160 but we just keep adding it on
so now we're at 337.
uh which is way more than what the
business is worth
so I just I just don't know where to
begin
um the personal side of it it's a big
mess of course but the businesses is
just stinking us what's your household
income
uh about 160.
of course
okay so your wife makes 160 or 190. oh
no I'm sorry uh so neither one of us
work in the business uh I make about 94
myself and then my wife makes 66. and we
don't take anything out of the business
ourselves but the business loses thirty
thousand dollars a year
it does yes approximal on your taxes
um somehow on the taxes this year is
showing as about 25 000 that income
but um
I'm not exactly familiar with with all
the accounting part of it but uh it
definitely doesn't feel like it's like
there's any net income every year it has
been getting better but it's still
pretty bad what kind of business is this
uh it's an ice cream shop
yeah we um yeah when you say you're
going in the whole 30 grand what is that
for is it expenses payroll what's
causing it yeah yeah it's pretty much
um just keeping the business afloat
um so as far as to pinpoint it I
really I guess it's just not having
having enough in sales
what could you sell the business for
today what's it worth I I did look into
that and that's about 60 000. as
business valuation that we got and that
was based on that 25 000 net income that
we got for this year yeah that's right
thinking what do you what do you do for
a living
uh I have a um I work for the government
uh Department of Defense
so my job is fairly stable my life what
what what is your what do you actually
do are you an engineer are you a oh well
no um basically uh we all have the same
position they call us analyst okay okay
I got you that's enough that's good
um
okay so you're working 40 hours there
I am yes and your wife does what for a
living
she's the teacher
um also um also works 40 hours although
currently she's at home with the baby we
have a newborn which is super quite the
surprise but um anyway she'll go back in
about a month or so
an aspect of the business it's we have a
mobile mobile uh part of it so I'm in
that quite a bit outside of my regular
job uh and that part of the business is
quite profitable
it's a shame I can't have that without
the the brick and mortar location but um
so I'm not in the store but I'm in the
Mobile Trailer going to events and such
what does it take to wind down the brick
and mortar location
uh
well
I mean if you can make 40 000 out of the
mobile
and shut that down
you could Whittle away at this
I could yes yeah
um
I'm not sure what that looked like I
guess the paying the fixed loan off the
um the original 160 000 I I guess that
would be the the biggest part
um is that alone that loans against the
location
it is yeah that's the original one and
then we just have other loans who is
that loan with
uh it was through a business lender like
a third-party business lender yeah
okay
um
so that payment is a little over three
thousand a month
yeah but if you were paying the payment
anyway and just close to the location
does that person does that put you in
default on the loan
no no I think we could do that but uh I
don't I don't know if well I'm just
saying jack up jack up your mobile and
run it all the time and get all your
costs gone
and let's see if we can't make this
thing make 60 and throw it all at it and
by the way let's take a whole bunch of
your 160 and start throwing it at it
let's live on nothing
like live on 60. let's go make another
100 let's go make another 60 out of the
mobile and shut down the brick and
mortar okay and uh now we got a clear
000 well no we don't we got a clear
um
uh 687 we got a minus 240. we got a
clear 447 because your mortgage is not
the problem okay uh 240 mortgage is not
your issue all right so if you add 60 to
your top
you following me here by by jacking up
your hours and you go crazy for two
years that puts you at 220 230 somewhere
in there right
okay yes okay and you live on nothing 50
Grand
you can clean this up really really fast
like two or three years of of
unbelievable hours and you can it's easy
to put in those hours if there's hope
and traction
if you're making progress and you
believe it's going to work I can work my
tail off it's when I'm feel like a rat
and a wheel that I get so exhausted
and you you've been a ratting a wheel
going backward for a while
yeah yeah I I've known better but I just
keep well and you're an analyst you've
been analyzing this watching it
um
as far as all the uh so of course we
have car loans and credit cards in that
mess too
um yeah now what
I was I was curious what your take on
and it's probably another bad decision
but that's what I want to ask you
um we have a good bit of equity in the
house should we should we consider
selling the house and using that Equity
to pay off only if you solve this
business problem
okay that would have to come first yeah
you've got to close this thing and
here's what I would do I would close it
and I would work like a crazy person and
I would sell everything inside except
the house
and I would and your wife your wife does
what for a living again she's a teacher
okay maybe she starts taking on some
tutoring on the side whatever anything
we can do to get our household income
way way up for the next 24 to 36 months
so here's the thing if you put a hundred
thousand dollars on this you're done in
four years if you put 150 000 on it
you're done in three years
and if you're making 260 you can put 150
on it and you're done in three years 100
debt free
and you still got the ice cream truck
not the location
and then sell it
the second part of this equation is
um
the
hopelessness the feeling of stuck that
you have
kept you from using your god-given
skills to dive into the numbers on this
business
and so I'm going to be your your boss
for a minute your leader and say your
job is to learn your numbers in this
business and know exactly what the
Flip's going on
you you let Jesus take the wheel and
Jesus told you to go plant corn
and if you plant sparingly you're going
to reap sparingly you have to be
diligent to know the state of your
flocks and herds you've got to get down
in this business and know these numbers
the fact that you don't know these
numbers when I'm asking you is part is
symptomatic of the fact you're not
paying enough attention to this thing
so you got to lean into it you got to
wind it down then you got to crank your
work hours way up and your income way up
and if that doesn't knock it out in the
next if you don't see the light at the
next 24 months then sell the house but
you can't sell the house until you get
rid of this business problem because you
you're not going to get rid of all the
debt
that's the thing there's no Escape patch
here except you you got to go do it
that puts us out of the Ramsey showing
the book so we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsaysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
foreign
[Music]